[Music]
all right tonight the unhinged angry
rage-filled Democrats their allies and
the hate Trump media Bob they're
continuing their smear campaign now
they're targeting Senator Lindsey Graham
after he encouraged Donald Trump jr. to
exercise his Fifth Amendment rights in
response to a Senate panel subpoena
about his Russian contacts for the
record Don jr. spent nearly 30 hours
testifying already when is enough enough
take a look it's progress yes you had US
senators telling the president's family
to ignore the rule of law that's nuts
by any Judiciary Committee yes yes I
know his numbers were horrible before he
started being Donald Trump's BFF but is
that worth it that's an answer you know
only he can provide Chris yeah Lindsey
if you have an issue with anything
you're I'm saying you know my number
baby give me a call okay let's help
these people out the fifth amendment is
the rule of law our rule of law is based
on a little document called the
Constitution of the United States but
the senator is standing strong
supporting president's agenda but it's
creating records in every on every front
exposing the deep state cabal by pushing
more FISA declassification securing our
border where he just unveiled a new bill
to reform the asylum process here to
explain more Senate Judiciary Committee
chairman Lindsey Graham himself you know
maybe I've it's been a long time since
I've been in school but the the fifth
amendment I thought was our right to
invoke do we don't have that did that
break it take it away and I missed it
well let me tell you why I weighed in on
this Moeller I thought was the final
word on all things criminal the last
thing you want shown is 535 special
counsels Richard burr is a good friend
of mine he's a great chairman in the
Intel committee he's going to issue a
good report I think telling us how to
deal with Russia in the future and what
happened on the Intel side what I worry
about is when's enough enough now you
got the house Intel committee breaking
accusations against
a secular and traditions lawyer right
you know Jared Kushner's lawyer that
they conspired with Michael Cohen to lie
to the house Intel committee what you
see happening is congressional
committees are now beginning to take the
place of prosecutors and that's
dangerous for us all and if I were Don
juniors lawyer I'd be reluctant to put
him back in the environment where two of
the people on the Intel committee in the
Senate are running for president of the
United States they want to impeach bar
they want him to resign they want me to
resign and they think Brett Kavanaugh
was Bill Cosby in high school these
people are going nuts well they wanted
jewelry
last I checked too not only did we have
a fifth of memory I think we have
something called the tourney client
privilege I think that exists I just
I've read that somewhere we play that
out a bit so so Nadler is going to get
trump reelected more than any single
person on the planet but that maybe yeah
yeah it's a close second but chef is
saying that he's going after the
president's lawyer
Abby Lowell Jared Kushner's lawyer based
on the word of Michael Cohen and what I
worried about what Don jr. is if we're
going to use Michael Cohen's testimony
will be going to Congress yeah you'd
have to get him out of jail to testify
but Richard Burr is a wonderful fella my
problem is not with Richard Burr my
problem is the system Richard burr you
and I differ here Richard I don't but he
spent 30 hours yeah now we somebody that
again was about a minute decline before
Congress okay right then a criminal
reform went forward by Jim Jordan and by
Mark Meadows about the second appearance
and so at this point I want to ask you
this so we are going to in the days
ahead we are going to get the FISA
applications Grassley for a memo known
as bulk of the application is Hillary's
bought and paid unverified dossier which
even the dossiers author doesn't stand
by and we're gonna get the 302 meeting
notes with or and Christopher Steele
then we're going to get the
material which I understand is not
really good about the FBI admitting
things they did wrong
the fourth bracket we talk about or a
series of emails that have some really
serious admissions in them amongst the
FBI and the fifth bucket will be exposed
OPA Tory statements that they didn't use
on purpose anything else that we're
going to find out our deep state did to
try and undo a president election
presidential election I think you're
going to get all of that hopefully it
will be declassified and given to the
public and I don't know if anybody on
the other side will care which will be
the sad thing you know all my friends
that sitting in or going to nuts over
you know my concern about Congress
getting out of its lane but have you
heard one person from these other
networks even show concern that maybe
the FBI bear gave a statement to the
FISA Court that the dossier was accurate
and they told other people that they
knew it was unverified have you heard
any concern at all about a
counterintelligence operation that was
being run by people who hated Trump and
like Clinton senator we now have two
sources that told the FBI and the DOJ
the upper echelon not rank and file I
always make the distinction yes right
they deserve that distinction those good
men that protect us but I am told in
both cases that with the dossier that or
warned him it was unverified Hillary
paid for it Steele hated Trump also now
we have the emails before the first
application went in it sounds like a
premeditated conspiracy to commit fraud
on a FISA Court and I'm also hearing
Horowitz is done and it's devastating
any word that you're hearing I can't
verify if Horowitz is done I can't tell
you what he found but I can tell you
that if you care about the rule of law
you're going to be very upset about how
the DOJ and the FBI behaved themselves
during the 2016 election if you hate
Trump you won't care if you love the
rule of law you'll be very upset senator
I will gladly endorse your re-election
and
the great state of South Carolina you've
been doing a great job thank you for
doing all these a few of you have been
leading on all of this and I know you're
going to continue with your promises to
follow up thank you for that